all right breaking just moments ago from
the Washington Post the Attorney General
of the United States Bill Barr has
expressed this agreement with the IDS
findings while serene disrupt
surrounding the origins of the Russia
probe that was not as original mandate
that is the mandated of John Durham now
if true it looks like well this explains
a lot doesn't it here for reaction this
huge development Senator Lindsey Graham
we expect alright you broke it right
here on this show one week from today
we'll get the IG report on FISA abuse
which is supposed to be FISA abuse
Durham was appointed as I understood it
for the origins of the Russia probe but
also that is now officially become a
criminal investigation expanding also
into FISA views and other issues the
inspector general is now power to
convene a grand jury is no power well I
mean for example he pointed out McCabe
and and call me Lac hander so nothing
happened as a result of that but here's
what I want to ask you is it not
incontrovertible that there were
multiple warnings to the FBI and DOJ not
to use the Clinton bought and paid for
Russian dossier that it was unverifiable
and that there was a bias of Christopher
Steele and a memo called the Grassley
grant memo said the bulk of information
for those applications was in fact the
unverified dossier isn't that doesn't
that now establish fact in this case I
believed it I believe it to be so but
Horowitz will see what he says but the
first thing I want to say is be wary of
the Washington Post in New York Times
reporting on what's coming up with
Horowitz they've been trying overtime to
spend this thing to diminish its effect
to downplay it I can tell you without
any hesitation Attorney General Barr has
every confidence in the world and mr.
Horowitz he believes he's done a good
job a professional job and he
appreciates the work in the effort he's
put in to disclosing abuse at the
Department of Justice
now here's what I do know in December
2017 sean mccabe testified in the house
according to the house in
tell memo that without the still dossier
there would be no warrant issued so what
I'm going to ask mr. Horowitz do you
agree with that without the dossier
there'd be no warrant yes the dossier
reliable to this day did they know that
still had a bias did they ignore it when
did they first try to verify it before
they got the warrant or after and here's
what I think we're going to find that
they pulled a fast one on the FISA Court
quite frankly misled and defraud
defrauded the FISA Court I think that's
what you're going to find okay so you'll
have him in your committee one week from
this Wednesday we get the report wait
for tonight I want to be very clear
though I think some of this would
explain the delay aspects of all of this
one
but I've been told clearly the facts are
devastating as he lays out the facts
that he may not make the conclusions but
that wouldn't be his purview anyway what
number one I have every confidence that
he's going to be fair to everybody the
people investigating and the public and
the Trump campaign and and all of us but
here's the point if there would have
been no warrant without the dossier the
question for me and everybody else as
well how reliable is the dossier did
they know it was unreliable when did
they first try to verify it before the
war or after the warrant were they
warned that Christopher still was out to
get Trump did they ignore those warnings
if all of that proves to be true it's
devastating every American should be
concerned in the FISA Court should do
something about it and if they accept
this as okay behavior then maybe we
should get rid of the FISA Court okay
agreed and by the way I would hate to
see that actually look at each other
there's a lot of evil in the world and
you know what there's a lot there's evil
I don't care if it's abroad or domestic
we have enemies domestic and foreign we
got to get to the bottom of this my
major concern in all of this is Horowitz
already referred you know for further
investigation McCain called me for lying
didn't Michael calm Paul Manafort
recently Roger stone run into issues
involving lack of candor that led to
guilty admissions convictions yeah so
unless unless he referred people
for prosecution call me they decided not
to prosecute based on what the Clinton
email investigation I trust bar to be
fair too so I don't know what's in the
report but here's what I do believe if
there was a counterintelligence
investigation of the Trump campaign and
there was credible evidence to open the
investigation why did they not tell
Trump when Dianne Feinstein was found to
have somebody in her office they
believed to be working for Communist
China they told Diane and she fired the
person if they're investigating a
campaign and they don't tell the
campaign about the foreign influence
then that truly is fine here's what I've
been told before the show that and what
is what I was told numerous times that
the facts that the IG will put before
the American people will shock the
conscience they will be devastating
to many people but it will be up to Barr
and Durham because the other hundred
percent it will be up to the Attorney
General
how percent and dirham and his report
and now a criminal investigation to
actually hold them accountable which by
the way no Inspector General has the
ability to convene it convenient a grand
jury make charges and prosecute do they
exactly he's not a prosecutor he's
looking to find out if the system got
off the rails how to protect it or how
to change it in the future how to make
sure it never happens again well the
best way to make sure that the FISA
courts not defrauded in the future is
hold those people accountable who
actually did the due process is it is it
then fair to say that there will be a
map that will be laid out by Horowitz
for the Attorney General for Durham and
they will also we all by the way we're
told that their investigation is far
more advanced than anybody knew at this
point I think that's a good way to look
at it you should look at this
investigation sword as a a road map of
where you might go okay criminally
whatever differences there are I guess
the person that decides would be the
Attorney General will be mr. doram I
just want to end with this one thought
if they're investigating my campaign and
they think somebody on my campaign is
influenced by foreign government
and they don't tell me and they keep
spying on my campaign I would be really
pissed every politician in America
should be worried about this if in fact
they opened up a counterintelligence
investigation of the Trump campaign and
they never told him about it then that
truly is spying in every politician
America joint worried a
counterintelligence investigation has to
start with the president that president
would have been Obama we're not done
this is just the beginning just the
history begins to unfold
finally Monday I hope it's not the late
again senator thank you we appreciate
your time